a big question for about the last 48
hours since the Texas church shooting
has been how was the gunman allowed to
buy guns or a different question I guess
is was he allowed to buy guns initially
it wasn't really clear what the case was
why is this even a question well it's a
question because the gunman was
convicted of domestic violence and he
was punished for it within the military
justice system
the law says very clearly that the
conviction that the shooter had for
domestic assault on his wife and her
toddler son should have should being the
key word should have stopped him from
being able to buy guns specifically the
four guns that he bought over the last
four years and there are 11 different
criteria at the federal level that
prevent people from having guns and the
Texas shooter met two of them conviction
of a crime punishable by a year or more
in prison he got a year for the crime
that he was was convicted of and
conviction of a domestic violence
misdemeanor or higher two criteria that
the shooter met but he was still able to
get the guns why we now have the answer
and the answer is that the air force
where the gunman served admitted that
they simply didn't put the gunman's name
into a federal database that's supposed
to prevent people with these types of
convictions from buying guns legally
this is a perfect example of how the
left and right are just never going to
get on the same page when it comes to
regulation in general like we'll get
back to the gun part in a second but
generally when it comes to regulation
when the left here is that a regulation
or a safety measure or some kind of
oversight protocol failed they say oh we
need to better fund and put more
resources into that system so that these
regulations will actually work when the
right here is that some kind of
regulations safety measure or protocol
failed they say see we told you
regulation doesn't work and we should
forget about the idea of regulation and
when it comes to guns arm everybody all
the time everywhere is it the fault of
this one person at the Air Force that
didn't report this one conviction not
really it's actually a
problem because records show that the
Department of Defense has received has
reported rather only one domestic
violence case to this federal database
for gun purchase background checks and I
can assure you that there has been more
than one instance of a member of the
military being convicted of domestic
violence so part of the problem is that
these convictions are systematically not
being reported the criticism from the
right is well
come on laws regulations they don't work
we aren't following the regulations
though the military isn't following the
regulations this is sort of like saying
Obamacare doesn't work because
Republicans are sabotaging it and making
it fail so what we should do is cancel
Obamacare rather than just fix the fact
that Republicans are actively trying to
sabotage Obamacare mandatory crime
reporting laws for federal gun
background check databases don't work
because the Air Force is ignoring the
rules so cancel all gun background check
regulations it's madness right it is
pure unfettered unmitigated madness if
you don't enforce the laws and
regulations that you have it makes it
very easy to say well more laws and
regulations won't change anything
because sure unless you stick to the law
the law is effectively meaningless and
now we have people that are dead dead 26
people dead and 20 injured just in this
one incident because the Air Force
didn't put the shooters conviction into
a database this is just computer work
right
if you're feeling hopeless about the
future of humanity I understand why
because we have the rules are we saying
that our own military isn't even well
enough equipped to input names on a
computer to a federal database is that
your position for why gun safety laws
aren't going to work because the
military can't be trusted
sort of a weird position to be taking
isn't it